right an event with eva longoria at uh
somewhere in hollywood
and i called uh
somebody a cracked out
[ __ ] horror scarecrow
hilarious and uh and so what did eva say
hey what's up everybody producer grant
here today's uh fantastic conversation
with polly shore being cut into two
pieces so first part this week second
part next week uh georgia's crazy
schedule popped up so
we ended up not being able to get in one
for an upcoming week so this wonderful
conversation is being divided into two
parts uh please enjoy part one hello
everyone hola mis amigos you're
listening to oh my god hi
with me george lopez
let's
you know george is oh i'm sure he's
around here somewhere what's his name
george
george lopez oh my god omg omg bye oh my
god
you know i think if there was a
historian that's not
that's still in the game somebody that
knows
where the bodies are buried somebody
or how would you say that espanol
says
[Music]
what brings you to uh
what brings you to me
well doctor
how have you been feeling them lately
i've known you forever but i've never
hung out with we've never hung out you
know what i mean it's like
you know uh you know i think the last
time i gave you a hug was probably
richard pryor's right richard pryor's um
funeral
and like you know a lot of the guys
i hated you for your success but okay it
was on a high level so congratulations
thank you it was wonderful to see it
happen it happened pretty fast yeah yeah
it was quick but um yeah so that was the
last time i gave you a big hug you know
because both of us were very very
affected by you know richard yeah
because we're around the same age so we
kind of grew up at the same time and and
he we were lucky enough to be able to be
friendly with him and to see him and it
was a [ __ ] it was a heavy funeral and
stuff and i remember seeing you and i
was just like [ __ ] up
you know you [ __ ] these guys are around
your whole life i mean you saw him you
grew up around him and you see him
deteriorate a little bit and then it
just i think if you deteriorate a little
bit he had ms early early 90s
and then he still loved it man he still
went to the store when he was sitting in
his wheelchair
and he was touring circle star theater
up near san francisco he was still doing
it oh really which meant he
was who he was man
yeah no he he you know i i had brought
him on a lot you know towards that time
my mom was there and
and you know we would kind of carry him
i think harris pete was there
yeah yeah this is before chewie and yeah
i think chewie was there a little bit
after that but um
yeah he was just uh you know till the
end he wanted the microphone in the sand
you know and that was as my dad too my
dad died at 92 years old and you know we
in this casket we put a microphone you
know what i mean because
you know that's that's what we do okay
so so people if they don't know your dad
was a famous comedian yeah and he opened
for every singer open forever barbra
streisand sammy davis i mean that's how
the whole thing started
you know is my my dad was you know he
hooked up with my mom in the late 50s
and he was performing at a place called
elkhart lake and they had sex and um and
then he got preg she got pregnant and
then you know and then the store was the
store after that but he was he was one
of the first stand-up comics in the 50s
you know he was touring he was a
catholic he was touring and then for a
stand-up comic
to have enough
wisdom and to be smart enough to say i'm
going to open this club on sunset it
used to be cyril
he um he got the offer from a guy named
frank senis who on the building and he
was just like he went to rudy de luca
and my dad rudy was his partner his
writing partner he says hey sam and you
want to open a room right here on sunset
yeah and and then he says you know rudy
let's you know let's do this and it was
like him and it was my dad and rudy
deluca and that was it started in 72 and
that's when like red fox was there and
pat mccormick and and even dave tyree uh
he had the natural gas which was with
vic dunlop right and all that [ __ ] and
um and lenny schultz and you know
michael keaton and all those guys so
that was the beginnings you know and it
was just you know it was a right place
right time and then my mom took it over
and then it just kind of blew up because
that's who she was she was a um she
liked to develop the comedians and
that's what she started with my dad
because she started developing my dad's
[ __ ] right and then it was just kind of
unnatural to her you know to develop
well the one the one thing about the
comedy story that hasn't changed is the
colors like black white and red like the
raiders bro and the and the sigh and the
signs still the same the signatures up
there and it uh it it is like uh you
know the getty house of comedy like you
go by the getty house it still looks the
same as it did you look at
uh the hearst castle still looks the
same you drop by the comedy store it
looks like it always has looked even
though the right house the highest house
next door
yeah don't let anybody jump up and
close all the balconies up yeah but but
let's talk about
like you said dave tyree so dave tyree
was almost like one of those guys like
robin harris who
like spike lee used to do the right
thing he had a heart attack in chicago
dave tyree was a funny [ __ ] dude man
yeah the best a killer hilarious how
does a dude like that not get a little
attention because he was on coke and
a lot of alcohol and he was like
following robin williams around and yeah
and it was just kind of a party and and
i don't know uh you know you could say
that for a lot of guys like mitchell
walters
and you know alan stevens is very funny
right you know a lot of these guys i
think he owns like a lot of the drugs
and and the alcohol and just kind of
like the time argus hamilton is a great
example of someone who's [ __ ] genius
and so good but because of the coke and
the drugs and and the alcohol i think
that [ __ ] him up well you know i think
back then too like you didn't go to the
store or you didn't go to a club
thinking about
being on tv because it was a smaller
thing you just worked about performing
see you tomorrow night you come tomorrow
night yeah i'll see you tomorrow night
on the weekends was great
it's always been the place to perform
it's always been the place to to be but
um
yeah i think it was uh you know you can
blame the drugs and the
you know in that era of of you know some
people not making it and also the people
that did the drugs they all died like
belushi and even robin you know was
pretty [ __ ] up with it for a while
dennison and and all these guys so it's
like um you know i had the saying that i
came up with a long time ago dance with
the devil don't become the devil which
is like it's okay to party dip your foot
in the water but don't do four day
bingers like and for me like you know i
was fortunate knock on wood that i
didn't have that bug in me you know to
to to to just go along you know you
never hear stories about me no going
like oh [ __ ] i party you know that's
like
you know i stayed out with paulie shore
for you know i just you know what i mean
i don't know if i'm jewish i don't know
if cause it's not in my system even when
i have a drink now like two is enough
yeah i don't need to keep going you know
and
and so i i i i learned that because
what do you think is the thing that
makes people drink and keep going like
you say you're happy with two now yeah
i've always been happy with two
you know i've always been that guy i
don't know i think
at the end of the day you know i just
have control you know what i mean i
think that's i just have control and not
to go over over over you know um
you know peek at it but don't you know
and i think that's you know was your mom
was your mom was mitsy shore was she um
in the business or what did she what did
she do before she met your dad um she
was just a kind of an artist you know
she was she went to school in wisconsin
at madison and she was like bohemian
yeah and she was just very much like you
know a bohemian chick
and she like you know liked arts and
that was kind of her thing but she was a
natural kind of development type person
because she did that with my father you
know she developed helped sammy do this
i tried this yeah just kind of was like
a natural
thing you know yeah um i saw your dad
too in vegas one time he was with
somebody like buddy hackie just hanging
out with some
with someone he did that my dad was part
of the um the friars club right back in
the day um you know where he was with
milton berlin caesar and and you know so
he was like you know so there was a
fires club in beverly hills yeah that
was the best one the best one they tore
down
and they put something there i had my
rap i had a wrap party for my first show
there was great wow then there's a
friar's in new york that's a great
building
um that's that's the other one i'm a
member you're probably a friar i'm a
friar i i haven't been a fire in a while
oh you could go in there and drink and
relax have meetings and do your thing in
there in privacy huh yeah yeah yeah yeah
that's what it was for for comedians oh
yeah do they still do like the roasts
and stuff they do events and
they do events in new york oh cool we'll
go grab calories here the um
was it natural that you were going to
become a comedian and an actor
um
i don't know i mean my brothers and my
sister didn't really get into it and
they grew up in it i mean i was just
always fascinated by it so like i would
go to the store i was like in awe of
like you know cheech and chong or i
would see lenny schultz or i would see
uh
uh you know um uh i don't know all the
guys that were there so i was just like
sure i was like you know like a kid like
everywhere a comic went i was there you
know so i just loved it you know so i
started it i started at in 12th grade is
when i started yeah you know that's when
i started was like 17 18 years old and
you'd be there and i just i hit like
yeah i hit quick you know and but i had
to i had the extra pressure on me
because it was mitzi's kid right so i
had to like you know and then the mtv
thing came and it just like took off
what was the first thing the mtv thing
that was the first big thing did they
want you did you audition no it didn't
wasn't like that it took a while oh yeah
yeah yeah yeah i mean i [ __ ] the bed
you know the first couple times
i was very nervous and i didn't really
know my my cadence and my character and
and anything just like i was 19 20 years
old so i was like trying to figure it
out um when they brought me down there
for spring break
right you know they brought in tv yeah
and it was just like you know i mean
even chris rock says it's like mtv at
that time was bigger than
saturday night live it was just like all
the kids went to mtv
you know to see what the [ __ ] was going
on and i just
great time right place and then when you
were rocked it had bangers ball they had
yeah
like hard rock rock hip-hop hip-hop yeah
heavy metal they covered
everybody watching everybody watched mtv
yeah so it was uh so that was that was
that was it and when i hit on that i
started drawing people at the store i
had like a following and then because my
mom didn't make me a paid regular for a
long time
it took a while and even when i became
known she still didn't want me to be a
paid regular she's like you're not ready
you know you're not ready and she's
right
you know just because it takes years to
really develop and get comfortable
you know on stage um i was at the store
last night and i was watching uh brian
holtzman um i don't know if you're
familiar with brian holtzman do you know
brian holtzman no you'll know him trust
me he's like a late night store guy yeah
and um
and you know rogan has kind of taken him
under his wing out in austin and and uh
bill burr just did a a special for him
last night that mike binder directed and
they filmed it and they filmed brian i
was so happy and i was so proud to see
um
you know to see him really pop because
he'd been at it for at least 20
something years yeah at the store trying
to [ __ ] you know trying to uh what's
up my man
uh i didn't i didn't do it please
don't dress up would you care don't
arrest me bro yeah
you know gill kill in the house
your career paulie shore coco you
it's an aaa meeting we're glad you could
show i'm glad i'm thanks for being here
i'm just an alcoholic
have a beer please i had all the alcohol
removed earlier in the day
i've seen you before
yeah yeah
because i know you guys i know that he's
he's in charge of all the uh
the the homicides in town
i'm just glad i'm not a i'm not a
homicide well the dude the guy that's uh
the guy that brian laundry he he uh
oh wow he he predicted where they would
find brian laundry when brian laundry
was on the run oh wow he said they're
probably going to find them in the
swamps that's right
deceased
and he did he said
so and they wouldn't find him in the
swamps either because there's no scent
that gets carried through there he
nothing here she was so he did he kill
himself
it's hard to say you know i i listened
to some guy later on after
uh was this after you had sex with him
bro he rolled over yeah but you weren't
talking about it
he went right to sleep yeah what did he
say that guy said he was a uh
former
uh green beret guy survivalist still
teaches like green beret [ __ ] survival
tactics
he said out there he says number one
he'd have to be sleeping in a tree he
could not sleep on the ground because
the critters everybody will get to him
[ __ ] there's no food he's got to know
what he's doing he's got to know how to
survive you know he's not just an
everyday this is serious business and if
he didn't do that
well then either the critters or the
animals are going to get to them right
so so
no no disrespect at all obviously i know
this gentleman i've known him for years
tell me a little bit about yourself so i
don't say anything improper there's
nothing you can have there's absolutely
nothing you can say it's going to be
improper yeah
yeah yeah i i i became uh
17 cop took me home told me to have my
parents sign get me off the streets
right being prisoner dead and this is
back in the 80s in in
our way 1967 right here in l.a
where we're from yeah east l.a east from
here well pico pika vera okay and and so
did that went in came out got matured
yeah
you said no he's from pequom yeah
how excited i was coming i was pissed
off because i had i'm late my battery
just don't ask me why it didn't really
do that probably in the [ __ ] car
listening to radio with it off yeah
oh this is no ac delco battery that
could run forever all i did was turn it
off to pump gas
to get down here and then yeah so just
give me your background really so came
back went to school went to college i
ended up marrying the girl that i wanted
to break up with because she had dumped
me when i was in vietnam it was dear
john she dumped me i want to get her
eating the palm of my hand got back six
months after all i want to do eat right
there and then i want to i want to break
it off with you and get revenge yeah
yeah six months after i got back we got
married okay and we just had our 50th
wedding anniversary 38 years as a cop 26
as a homicide so 30 so you're a cop
still retired no retired a matter of
fact this month uh
we'll be 12 years retired but he'll
still say he'll still like yeah you know
like scooby-doo he'll still get in his
[ __ ]
escalators
what type of cop is he
i was a good cop no but what it was
in the sheriff's department my specialty
was homicides oh wow okay so you did the
the the was it the the
side strangler no hillside strangler my
partner worked on frank salerno i worked
on the i was the kodi investigator with
him on the night stalker richard
nightstalker because i remember the
night stalker because i grew up on
sunset strip so i remember in the 80s it
was the 80s right 85 richard ramirez
1985 russell yeah i remember yeah i
remember that so you so so
why are there so many crime crime
documentaries and why is everybody so if
you watch netflix you just like there's
no comedy there's no this i mean you got
chappelle a couple things
but it's all about who killed this and
who killed that and the thing that i
don't like about all those documentaries
is that it's good
for a while like like people are talking
about but i want to see the [ __ ] guy
no you don't need anything like that
right
but no not him but any of the killers
well why do you think that we have a
fascination with that because people
want to kill other people they're
fascinated by the way like i think
they're just fascinating they're
armchair detectives they want to be able
to solve them that's what true crime is
about these people just want to get out
there and think it's easy to go ahead
and solve these crime you know they
think they know because they watch it
and that's why they're doing their but
why are we as a society so fascinated
with movies in documentaries of of slave
because like
what is it hln if hl didn't have murders
or if there weren't murders and hlm
wouldn't exist and hln was kind of like
they did showbiz today they did news
and now it's all uh how it really
happened and questions like that are
above my pay grade those are for doctors
i don't even know what hln is
it's a cnn it's a part of the family
headline news news
but they don't do news anymore just just
slide lines just like oxygen used to be
touchy feely movies now they got oxygen
it's a crime channel yeah so why are we
so fascinated with watching crimes i
have i can't answer that really i'm a
simple-minded mexican from the
neighborhood just happy to be here
excited to be here with two icons
actors comedians i mean this is but i
think they glorified manson so they just
kind of daisy chained through like
manson hillside strangler
ted bundy dahmer um
zodiac zodiac killer
so through the years there's kind of
strong things along i think if maybe
they had gone away maybe it would have
gone away but they hadn't come away yeah
i really don't know they're bringing
back they just brought back uh the
toolbox killer
and these were guys who were picking up
girls and taking them on torturing them
and it was it was ugly wow and nobody
even knew about it then
you know i knew about it because i was
working homicide at the time
and lead investigator a good friend of
mine you know we i knew all about the
case
but you never heard about it social
media wasn't around then
none of this problem so now all of a
sudden it's being resurrected because
uh true crime is is do it do detectives
like do detectives still
with dna and all that now
is it is it
what's the process if paulie and i are
officers and you show up
and let's say grant's dead i think
that's a tv show [ __ ] this whole thing
like that
he's clinging to life
you and him are leading detectives we
step out of the way and we tell you as
you come in what happened we came in
this guy was laying down
you know spread i i got to believe
people ask me all the time
in light of what we have available to us
today with dna and
all the
forensics that are out there would you
have solved the night stalker quicker
yeah i don't know because he didn't have
you know even dna back then look at that
[ __ ] had a toothache she'd still
be running out there exactly well
today's serial killers if they're out
you know if they're and i'm sure they're
still out there
they're much sharper they're staying up
with the times so they know what they
got to do to avoid prosecution because
murder is uh it's an irrational act
followed by acts of rationality but
they're all they're all uh egomaniacs oh
yeah
richard says i got an ego that will fill
this room they all they all are what
about the people that go for go in
prison for crimes they didn't commit
you know like you watch uh what is it um
you know not the tiger king the other
one uh
you know the other big murderer thing
with the
you know what i'm talking about sure
there there are there are those guys and
i watched that called the bad lawyer
what is that i did it it's called a
bunch of screws right
i watch some of these programs
and i sit there and i and i tell if i'm
watching my wife's right there well
that's a [ __ ] up confession
you know they're feeding them all the
information he's regurgitating what
they're telling them you know hey you
can't do this you can't do that and so
when you make mistakes like that at the
investigative level and i just watched
one the other day and my daughter is
sitting there saying dad how could they
do this
well [ __ ]
they only had one murderer you know like
in three years here it is and these guys
are handling it
and the same thing with the
the uh shooting the the actor that just
did the yeah oh the uh yeah are you
watching yeah i've been following that
yeah you watch that
those comps have never had a problem
like that before they're handling the
media sorry it's a bizarre and it's used
so much did you guys ever use a gun in
movies yeah we did it um i don't know
the army movie we did a while ago we did
yeah we used all that [ __ ] but it was no
no real real [ __ ] gun but you know
the first thing that goes on a small
movie like that is safety yep the first
thing that [ __ ] goes because even
even they had issues earlier in the
shoot but then that morning the camera
crew walked out they're like [ __ ] this
man it's just dangerous and then that
happens how do they find 500 rounds
it's [ __ ] weird man that's strange
what
is stood on
that's
what does that say darkness
charlie murphy
oh wow
so do you close with charlie yeah
crazy huh crazy yeah didn't want to go
to the doctor
what did he go to the doctor he had
leukemia
but he didn't want to go to the doctor i
think if he would have gone
earlier than when we mentioned it to him
but you know i think he was afraid
people are afraid yeah
i went i just had my uh i just had my
brain scanned yesterday
because i have an ear thing and i don't
have a ear it's called a i think it's
called like eustachian tube dysfunction
of a fullness in my ears so like my ears
are always full all the time for the
last like five six years where um or you
know how you fly in a plane uh and then
your ears are clogged and you go like
this they de-clog yeah well my shit's
always clogged
so i went to the i went you got to go to
the mri they go a cat scan an mri they
do everything right there and then they
tell you you know they tell you and the
doctors invest in the business he says
you shouldn't do it you're good
because you don't want to start cutting
you know what i mean
until they do that it's really nice what
caught what what causes that
they don't know you know i thought it's
kind of like cancer you just don't know
you know what i mean like my friend died
of a brain tumor cancer it's just like
how do you get like i don't [ __ ] know
just one day do they put tubes in there
for that i did that already
i went what happened was i went to cedar
sinai
and i asked their doctor for a year and
he couldn't figure out i said who's your
version at ucla
so they sent me to this guy gopin and
they did a scan and this was all before
covid and they said oh you have this
kind of fullness thing
but
back to charlie murphy it's like you
know and i'm like as they're checking my
head i'm like do i have cancer tumors
and all that [ __ ] because they could
tell so thank god
you know none of that [ __ ] good you know
what i mean it's scary to be sick
oh yeah you know because you're not
going to get better overnight everybody
wants to get better faster and when
you're really sick
you got to stay diligent and go to the
doctor or not
and if you have pain or you have uh
discomfort go to a doctor because
if you don't go you can't win you won't
beat it whatever it is so what do you
think about what's going on now in our
world the comedy world just about
sensitive and yeah all that [ __ ] how are
you how are you working i i i still work
the way i always worked out yeah yeah i
don't think that uh
um
i mean they're [ __ ] jokes man
seriously i mean if if
if a politicians would say it i would
take it more serious than a [ __ ]
comedian yeah i mean we're supposed to
say [ __ ] that doesn't make any sense or
that's mean yeah you know comedy is
about when [ __ ] goes wrong not when it
goes right but you've also been the type
of comic
where you never really crossed the line
anyways even before this yeah you kind
of went to the line right kind of hit
the line that's always been my style as
well yeah i never was like the guy that
you know i maybe say things here and
there but it's out of like love right
and it's oh [ __ ] uh so i didn't mean to
say that you know what i mean that type
of [ __ ] but i was never that guy but i
mean you look at you look at uh
tick tock like we talk about that guy
that raider that had was flashing
weapons and uh tick tock so anybody you
know there's some funny there's some
funny people on tick tock um
they wouldn't last on a stage but but
for create creation and content they're
funny you got a little they get a little
following there it's it's it's
interesting um and this is something
that i'm sure you're dealing with
you know when me and you started you
know back in the 80s or 90s or whatever
that time was there was not you know
you know you wanted to get on tv you
wanted to get on the stage you go to la
new york right and you you know you
worked your way up and that and that was
just like the conveyor belt and that was
it and that was the way you did it
period even to up to like the last 10
years and now because of social media
like the guys like us i don't want to
say the talented guys but the guys that
have put in the work
um um are kind of getting deluded you
know what i mean a little bit and i i
get like you know we prevail like we'll
always prevail but still at the end of
the day
more people are watching you know the
comments
on their tick tock or their comments on
their own [ __ ] right you know what i
mean like we never had that i don't want
to say competition
because it's not they're not competing
against us but they're still [ __ ]
you know putting their face you want to
read some bad ones
putting their face on camera right you
know like
you know like when we were growing up
there's what
10 networks maybe 15 at the most and now
there's thousands no there's thousands
you know and
i think pretty soon
tvs are going to be obsolete
and they're you know because you're
going like i got this house and i'm like
oh [ __ ] how many tvs do i want in it and
i'm like well not a lot because most
people just watch their [ __ ] on their
computer right
you know what i mean it's like i
honestly think that like tv
they talked about a time when nobody had
a tv
in their wall because they they do it on
their computer or they're happy looking
at it on their phone
and they want to be able to move around
yeah instead of sitting in one place for
[ __ ] 10 hours watching the making but
it's interesting but it's interesting
you know like you're in a coma you know
in the 90s and you wake up now and
everyone's like at the coffee shop just
staring at the things and you're like
what the [ __ ] is going on
and and you know and and then you go to
starbucks and you say they say okay
that's you know a certain amount of
money you try to give them cash and like
we don't take cash here yeah and you're
like oh it's apple pay
you know what i mean oh we don't i mean
there's so many places that don't take
care of a [ __ ] grubhub or or
postmates you put it in your phone
you say what you want everything's safe
and also even like you know i went to
the the concert last week they're
rolling stones or guns and roses or
you're going to there's no more ticket
stubs you know how like i was with my
brother scott and i'm like
he's like oh i want to go take a piss or
go get a beer i'm like well you can't
give him his ticket because i got him
they sent me on the email on my computer
i mean there's something cool about
holding a ticket i'm not saying all the
concerts but that's kind of how it's
mostly i
i have it on my on my phone
but i just i'm i'm in that trend i still
don't trust this yeah give me a paper so
i print it out and i have it for my
pocket a
just in case i don't think anybody saw
technology going that way like you know
um dude it's intense when guys would
record their sets they did it on a
cassette recorder yeah yeah yeah yeah
never video until by the 1990s and then
when you're when you're on stage do you
care if someone takes a picture or films
your set
um
i try i do care but i i they got people
that take care of that i know but but
what happens if you find someone in the
audience that's that's filming and you
see it do you say and see you say
something um
yeah i do i used to say more but they do
a pretty good job of
you can't stop everybody in there but
yeah if i see it i'm i'll make them i
think all the clubs should have yonder
you know the case
yeah i think every [ __ ] club should
have that what's you under it's a it's a
pouch
so you go in i was gonna put your
[ __ ] phone on it before i interview
but you know when it's [ __ ] buzzing
yeah i'm like this [ __ ] shows up
you know put it no it's basically
you know they take it from you and you
put it in there and it's a bag that pops
you out and if you want to use the phone
you go outside and use it and like you
get to hold on to your phone but it's in
like a pouch that you can't open right
way better
because as a comic
you know we write
but we also write on stage right
and then you know and that was like you
know how we develop our stuff and if you
have to think about you know that's
what's [ __ ] up about a lot of stand-up
because you know i want to go up there
and say what the [ __ ] i want to say and
i don't want to you know say something
racist or you know like yo [ __ ]
i'm just trying to figure this [ __ ] out
on stage i did it i did
and i called uh
somebody a cracked out
[ __ ] horror scarecrow
hilarious and uh and so what did eva say
she said i know you're not talking to me
[ __ ] and when i got home on the
bottom of channel nine the feed i had
that i had was expecting to get a call
from somebody
they're calling them up you're also a
little disney ass
you know george lopez
what do you mean disney asks well you're
americana
yeah your style you're like very
american yeah
you know so you represent
you know you're not the underbelly you
know kind of raunchy comic you're like
very um disney ass like i mean i'm not
saying you're a disney guy but you're a
you're a
you're american i do a little bit of
everything
well we know that but you're still known
yeah i'm known as america too yeah you
know yeah mitzi sun and you know blah
blah blah and i had the podcast
but i think our images are and gill's
known from [ __ ] el salvador
el salvador dude
you ever run into do you ever run into
somebody who was driving 156 miles an
hour and hit somebody
no and i'm glad i wasn't
i was driving 80 the other day i'm like
going i'm thinking of that dude i'm like
80s fast
you know i've driven they add another
fifty i got another residential [ __ ]
oh my god i've given a car 110 miles an
hour
on duty
on duty and i'm sitting there saying i
can't imagine how anybody can handle the
car today's car street cars
any faster than that you know because it
they're very very sensitive was he
blacked out drunk yeah oh [ __ ] yes yeah
driving with no recollection probably
not right 150 well you knew right after
it happened because you're out there
crying like oh look uh oh you know he
just threw an awful lot of weight but
it's he's he's sad today
yeah well i think his blood alcohol was
like 1.16 but that was after they got to
the station so he's 22 years old so
they're sentencing him this week or next
week oh he hasn't even they haven't even
had a hearing on him yet
so what should take about 40 years you
think uh probably not he's never had a
he's never had a record he's never done
this he's well known he's been good
so they're going to swallow thank him
but it's still it's still going to be
murder he's probably going to get you
know somewhere between 15 25 years yeah
you'll get probation because you've got
no record you know yeah yeah
it happens
i feel sorry my art goes out as it
always does to the victims and their
family members
but the realities are the way socialism
is today the way they socialize
everything
well he really wasn't a bad guy didn't
do that much bad so you sentence this
guy
you know
40 years in prison
when local guys here that are using guns
to intentionally kill people don't get
that kind of time what do you think
about the um this whole like um
i don't want to call it a liberal
movement but like the movement of
people
breaking into cbs and just stealing
stuff and not being arrested but you
know you know what i mean this petty
thing you see it yeah it's very common
now especially what it is like seattle
or
l.a like like people are doing it not
only in stores or doing it in
restaurants yeah they just go and order
food and then get up how long do you
think until a republican becomes a
president again and he starts to go
until we get we've got to do a couple of
things
uh we got to
we got to recall the current district
attorney right now for los angeles at
least locally i don't know i'm not going
to start is that
no garcetti
not lately his son eric is is the mayor
but the new one right now is uh gascon
and he just
letting everybody go free not filing
much so is it george is it is it the
thousand dollar or wait is it like 200
anything under 200 they just leave it
alone they're not doing anything a
burglar which is a felony
right now a burglar gets arrested goes
in gets booked gets interviewed and then
they give him a ticket to get out of
jail it's [ __ ] crazy dude yeah
because he's not finally not violent uh
cases right now he's not doing a lot so
you're saying if i went and stole a
snickers at like some some depot thing
and they caught me they would put me in
jail or they wouldn't no they'd give you
a ticket let you go right there it's
crazy
yeah then there's no deterrent to being
a shoplifter what is there there is
absolutely no deterrent or if you're
hungry you go into
a market and grab some
some stuff and walk out with it that's
it yeah i don't know that's and they
just released uh
uh a
a murderer a kid was just a couple of
months shy of his 18th birthday so they
they filed murder they convicted him as
an adult is this the guy in the little
white kid in in uh
in the middle of the country no no this
is right here in l.a county make a copy
and he was 18 years old you know they
prosecuted they said they prosecuted him
as an adult well now it's up for review
and so
gascon
is refusing to refile
as a juvenile
they you know he's done time enough time
already let him go so he's going to get
out he's he's walking out
you know and and this was all with a new
district attorney for los angeles county
right now was he the one that decided
about this whole uh you can shoplift and
it's all good yeah
wow why did you decide to move to to las
vegas because you know
your mom was here the store all those
years
right your dad
and to leave los angeles california for
somebody like you because you grew up
here yeah it's a big deal yeah and
when did you decide a lot of it was just
you know um i'd been here my whole life
you know i'm 53 yeah i grew up at the
store since the 70s
i didn't know anything else but that
um la started to shift
you know because of what was going on
obviously and um i wanted uh my parents
both passed
yeah
yeah my parents passed and um
and i was fighting with my brothers you
know i was fighting with them
and everything settled and i just wanted
to be happy and i just wasn't la just
didn't represent happiness to me good
for you um you know in vegas to me you
know my dad's widow's out there i got a
lot of close friends there it's show
business it's close and to me you know
vegas represents happy right it's just a
very happy place you know obviously
unless you you lose all your money but
if you're having a good time you're just
going to you go to the wind you can sit
down have a nice dinner you go to
bellagio you guys saw rod stewart last
you know a week ago i saw the stone it's
just like a really fun there's a laugh
factory there aries there it's just it
represents happy i think after a while
you you you take the part of vegas
that's for you and you leave the rest
like if you want to go to a show
you'll have dinner you go to the show
you go home yeah so you could start i
was in vegas just a couple weeks ago i
did absolutely nothing other than had
lunch with a good friend had dinner with
a good friend
didn't do much relaxed
calmed down
before i had to fly back to the zoo that
we have here in l.a what's the liability
of that place top golf
over serving that dude and letting him
drive off oh [ __ ] what happened is there
i don't know
i don't know which guy you're talking
about the football player oh is that
where he was yeah
oh well then there's going to be a lot
of liability somebody was serving them
booze and if they can show who it was
because
well i don't know he was on the raiders
again yeah i don't know
over in las vegas but over here
certainly civilly liable
you know somebody's going to be at fault
for allowing him to do that somebody's
going to lose a chunk of their ass
for that yeah but also
as far as as far as um
la
you know la's my heart right you know
this is where my family is and this is
where all my close friends are
and it doesn't mean i'm not coming back
i still have a house here and i still go
back and forth yeah it's good and and
you know i like l.a because it's got a
lot of creatives right i mean there's
all the people behind the scenes even
people that work here like you know they
talk my language yeah you know and vegas
if you you're looking for a cameraman
and you're like yo let me see your reel
they send you the reel looks dope but
it's just like bottle service babes and
a dj right you know what i mean
you know what i mean yeah and and uh
and vegas is uh you know it's it's it's
it's got what it's got
it's um
do you have uh do you have a residency
somewhere
no but i'm really not interested in a
residency thing you know because i don't
want to be locked in to anything in my
life
you know i like to bop around if i want
to go on the road
yeah i can fly and go on the road you
know like you know you look at guys like
carrot top you know yeah he's making
money but i mean his life is like he's
just there all the time
and it's kind of like prison you know
what i mean you're getting paid but you
ha you have to go there every night
golden handcuffs yeah and it's like um
i like to bop around danny ganz before
him
danny ganz was uh at the mirage all the
time
mr
what george wallace was he died yeah he
died in the late 2000s yeah yeah it's
just uh i mean obviously if they throw
millions and millions of dollars at you
then you think about that
but
i don't know being older things get
short man exact that's what i'm saying
you [ __ ] go do the thing by the time
you get home and you sleep and you wake
up
you eat and you're like man i gotta
[ __ ] go over there i know days are
short [ __ ] and i'm not an entertainer
and i know what you think these are
short yeah you know you get older and
the the only thing you really have is
time you know um you know i say i have a
saying where i say steak tastes the same
you know whether you're a billionaire or
a millionaire you know what i mean it's
like you go to you go to a [ __ ]
you know you go to a statement
yeah you go to the palms you get a stake
and the bill comes it's you know it's
two three hundred dollars whether you're
you're you know
you got a lot of money a little money
yeah and for me
you know i've never been um
kind of a flashy type of person you know
my whole life right and i think that has
a lot to do with growing up in it i saw
people go up and down and i'm like
oh like i'm just not one of those people
that likes to spend a lot of money
because the money doesn't
materialistic things don't make me happy
you know i mean like that's why i love
the internet you know we doing [ __ ] like
this we don't have a big we don't have a
[ __ ] big 50 people right you know
watching us you can't say that i mean
you were doing your show i'm sure you
had to deal with that [ __ ] and ratings
and all that and it's like at the end of
the day you know
this is what we do
you know whether you do it at this level
or a big level it doesn't matter yeah
how did i saw the movie guest house i
liked it thanks uh how did that come
along who
um the gentleman who uh wrote it named
sam sam macaroni um and his buddy sean
sean macaroni shondu macaroni
they uh they uh i guess they um they had
the script idea it was fun yeah they had
a script idea and uh
and then they came they a guy saw me and
joe rogan and they're like oh [ __ ] this
guy should be starring in movies like
yeah you know he's been doing movies
this whole like why isn't he doing
movies right and then i read the script
and i'm like yeah this is [ __ ]
awesome you know it's a great idea me
stuck in the guest house you know and
then not wanting to you know [ __ ] around
and then i went in there and poly eyes
it and made it you know soft i softened
it and made it more brought in more
heart to it and worked with the team and
we knocked it out you know what had it
had a good ending it was fun
it was good yeah it's a good movie yeah
it's a cute movie was on netflix or yeah
it's on netflix now what's your name
guess now you should see it no i will
it's good man cause you've seen paulie
in movies and then you're like oh all
right and then you see the story evolve
and then at the end
yeah you feel good yeah it's a heart
felt made a [ __ ] good movie man i
like that i like happy hating i don't
like to watch that yeah
i'm a touchy feely feel good guy yeah so
um
who were some of the late night who were
some of the late-night comedians like
there's that last spot right that late
spot a lot of that that's holtzman i
told you about who he was the one were
the ones that came out of there kennesaw
well you got [ __ ] i mean
if you do if you went last at the comedy
store
that late spot was the spot where
if you did that mooney was there mooney
was there paul mooney was going to be
able to remove he would sit on the stool
yep you know and have his moe
and he would just you know start going
it was hilarious
the thing that i liked about mooney he
didn't give a [ __ ] about if he got a
laugh
he would just start speaking and then
people would start walking he'd be like
[ __ ] it go you know and then eventually
you know he [ __ ] hit
you know and then like the last 10 15
years of his his career his life he was
[ __ ] selling out and i was like thank
you you know because he would always he
was always like richard pryor's guy or
just this guy and he never but like his
[ __ ] finally paid off never wavered on
i2 on itunes go look up uh he has a
couple albums but the first one was
should have won a grammy it's called
race
uh paul mooney i've listened to so much
paul money all i ever listened to
when i'm traveling from point a to point
b down here
kevin hart laugh factory and laugh
comedy central
canadian company that's all i listen to
where before it was all oldies you know
that's all i live but for the last
five six years you think that porn do
you think you could listen to porn
like a satellite like porn channel where
you just hear people
well there ain't no doubt in my mind i
could
but this uh this uh this gentleman this
gentleman that runs this this uh network
here yeah bill burr i mean forget about
it [ __ ] forget about it i saw him
last night and i you know me i've seen
everyone i mean i've been around trust
me i've been around i've seen it all all
these [ __ ] guys and i just [ __ ] i
took a gummy and i was sitting next to
mike binder last night with a girlfriend
and he just [ __ ] just
oh i was dying [ __ ] dying yeah yeah
dying and he's you know he's like
chappelle i think him and chappelle are
the two guys that can kind of just say
[ __ ] you
i'm just gonna do this because funny's
funny you know what i mean and he's not
a racist guy bill's not racist and and
chappelle's not you know anti
uh transgender and all that stuff but
you know they they go there and it's
like [ __ ] awesome yeah but you're
supposed to go there sure
you know there are no
limits but there's a difference between
going there and being funny and going
there and being not funny [ __ ] burrs
[ __ ] funny dude like he did this
whole thing on abortion i'm like yes you
saw that [ __ ] yeah i saw it it's from a
couple weeks [ __ ] you well you were
there
i mean how great is the [ __ ] i mean it
was so and he like he got distracted
because something was going on in the
crowd so he ended up like moving that
bit around okay and so he was talking
later about how like i didn't love where
it showed up blah blah it's normally my
closer it's like here we go you did like
15 minutes in and it was still [ __ ]
hilarious
yeah and you know as a comic you're
sitting there going how the [ __ ] does he
come up with this how does he develop is
he right because i know kenneth sent him
bill told me this that sam like when sam
did his his touring he never wrote
anything
you know you and i i write i got
i got pamphlets of [ __ ] jokes
because that's how i work but sometimes
i'm thinking like maybe you shouldn't
write anything and you should write it
all on stage right and just work small
clubs you have to record it and keep
track of it but just trying to find the
real
whatever it is as opposed to being in
your head which is [ __ ] up for comics
because the worst thing to do is to be
in your head but if you're writing jokes
you're in your head because you're
trying to [ __ ] remember your joke but
these guys like i think i assume bill
doesn't really write anything down he's
right
he doesn't write anything down goes yeah
he just goes that's [ __ ] that's
pretty [ __ ] amazing but not only is
it amazing it's it's it's it's it's
probably the best thing to do especially
for an older comic like us
like [ __ ] the material that you write
like just try to and but he goes up a
lot though he does in his podcast too
like he's not necessarily exactly he's
not necessarily like doing the bits on
his podcast but i'm a listener and you
can connect the dots yeah a couple
months you're like oh that made an
interview yes
you know what i mean
so start [ __ ] practicing your jokes
out on me dude let's go [ __ ]
come on you're the guest start firing
away yeah
you